Everyone loves French toast in my house,
so when my toddlers requested it this morning,
I decided to just make it for them.
I started off by making my brioche bread by adding some yeast flour
milk to my bowl and letting that activate.
Then I added in all of my eggs,
some more flour, and needed that dough until it all came together.
Once it started coming together and forming a dough,
I cut up some butter
and slowly drop that in until it was all incorporated.
Then I covered that and let that rise until it was doubled in size
before portioning it off in three portions.
I rolled those out until they were about 9 inches long,
pinch the top together,
and then braided it up
and tuck the bottom under so it would create a seal.
I placed my dough into my loaf pan
and let that rise until it was about doubled in size.
In the meantime,
I kept my mixed Berry compote
by combining some frozen berries with some maple syrup
and lemon juice
and letting that reduce on the stove.
Once that came together,
I transferred it over and let that cool in my bowl.
I brushed my brioche with some egg wash
and pop that in the oven for about 35 minutes before pulling it out.
I let that cool while I made a quick whipped cream is.
Who doesn't love French toast with whipped cream on top?
At this point, my Bread was cool enough to slice,
so I cut it into slices,
making sure that they weren't too thin
before I combined my egg with some heavy whipping cream,
vanilla and cinnamon to dip my bread in.
I coated both sides and then placed my bread in a buttered up pan.
I fried it until it was golden brown and and it was time to plate.
I put my French toast down,
topped it with the mixed Berry compote, whipped cream,
and I also had some passion fruit lying around and the kids love it,
so I put that on top and they absolutely loved it.